he's known for his roles in the hit TV
shows Lucifer suits and 24. in his new
TV show is called the night agent it is
so good he plays secret service agent
Eric monks who's returning to the job
after a long Hiatus in one scene he
tells his team leader the truth about
why he was away for so long after taking
a bullet for the president
I know you're an addict I know they
forced you into rehab and I know that if
you were anyone other than the boss's
old partner that never have put your
back on in detail
miss anything no you're mostly right
getting shot that started me on
painkillers it wouldn't look good to
have me wash out so they said if I
stayed clean for a year that I could
then I could start back at the bottom he
said mostly right
yeah
you said I was an addict
I still am always will be that's
supposed to make me feel any more
confident I don't really think he's an
addict DB Woodside dog this is at the
table good morning welcome good to see
you David Brian what's side because I
bet your mom's watching since she lives
in uh my mom is probably glad to have
you at the table yes it's not like the
name DB yes
you know listen I plan to watch a couple
of episodes two or three it's ten
episodes I watch all 10 episodes because
this show this series is that good and
you are knockout in it so Bravo it takes
many twists and turns that's what I
liked about it but you say of all the
characters you've played and you played
many this one is closest to you how
um it's uh well the role itself is just
really kind of gritty and it's about
someone who is battling this drug
addiction after doing something really
great and when I was much younger I you
know explored that area and I think a
lot of addicts sometimes
use to kind of numb the pain of things
that they're going through
um but he has it as well when I was much
younger you were much younger yeah but
you you say that you're an introvert I
said how can you have this job and be an
introvert I know the roles you play uh
that surprises a lot of people but it's
um
um it's a wiring of the brain you know I
uh yes there are a lot of actors that
are extroverts but there are quite a few
of us that are introverts as well which
means we like to go to work do our job
and then when the job is over we need to
go home to recharge before we can go
back so you're not going to see us out
you don't really see me we're not going
to see you at the parties you're not
going to see me at the parties no yeah
it's basically turning on the light
switch right yes when you go back to
work you it's so you flick it on your
eye one and you do your job and people
interact with you and you interact with
people they think he's so great yeah and
you go home and you're like exhausted
yes exhausted if you want to reach me
text yes that's it so to prepare for
this role you put out a call you play
secret service agent you put out a call
on Twitter I think it was or on social
media to meet with any uh past Secret
Service agents did you actually meet
with any and what'd you learn um I
talked to uh I mostly talked to to uh
people that had uh served uh I talked to
one uh Secrets ex-secret service agent I
talked to a guy that was in the uh
Rangers uh Noah pandia and I talked to
uh my friend
um uh Amy who was on Lucifer uh her her
boyfriend uh served as well and uh all
three of those uh incredible men
um really taught me a lot and shared
stories with me and it really helped to
get into the mindset of this guy they
were fantastic more about why you know
to be a secret service agent you have to
take a bullet potentially for the person
you're protecting that is the job
description it's actually not the person
we're not taking a bullet for the person
you're taking a bullet for the
institution amazing amazing and when you
start thinking about it that way it's
very different I hadn't thought of it
you're there to protect the institution
but you're still taking a bullet yeah
you are taking a bullet you could end up
dead like d-e-a-d dead yes so I want to
go back to you being an introvert
because I'm so fascinated by you in
terms of your idea of a perfect night in
and how you view your job and how much
you still like your job what's your idea
of a perfect night in for you oh my gosh
uh a perfect night in asking for a
friend is uh uh having a glass of wine
with a really good book or
um a great show that I haven't had the
chance to to see
to kind of binge watch that and um you
know I'm fortunate enough to have a
little gym at home uh a gym at home yeah
work out maybe have one friend over and
uh have have dinner uh go for a walk I
need to change chairs with Tony
an elliptical and a rowing machine it
definitely has a treadmill okay uh not a
rowing machine okay and not a uh
elliptical okay well we can work on that
and what else would we be doing just
pretending here
um you can use your acting skills at
this moment all right uh do you like
walks yes yes okay yes um I got some
tennis shoes all right I like walks
through neighborhoods because I like to
look at different the different
architecture of homes I think it says a
lot about an area do you like dogs I
love dogs me too absolutely love dogs me
too me too do you cook yes
um I try oh gonna be ordering in okay
but I ain't gonna be ordering in yes how
to get better yeah uh so me too Tony yes
when we go to commercial we need one of
those Graphics of the heart
really I got so liked about your show
all all kidding aside you were so good
the show is so good and I can't wait for
people to see it and see how good you
are in it thank you very much cheering
you on always thank you nice job and we
love Lucifer and I loved you in The
Temptations played Melvin Franklin I
love the Temptation did you
wasn't that great Gail wait okay sorry
we love it for different reasons I have
a little pitch uh this year is going to
be the 25th anniversary of The
Temptations and I think it would be
great for NBC to get us all back
together again and talk about yes come
back and bring some friends would your
mother like me my mother would love you
I I know for a fact my mother does love
you
good to go good to go a phone call in
about five to ten minutes I'm telling
you that right now thank you
thank you nice to meet you Mrs one time
you can watch the night agent starting
this Thursday I'm on the right camera oh
it's on Netflix